so today we're here talking about
angular and the case for rxjs so arcgis
is reactive extensions for javascript
it's a library for working with strings
of values that usually change over time
the ArcGIS operators enable you to write
complex asynchronous code in a more
declarative and composable manner and so
this reactive programming model was
originally created at Microsoft for
dotnet but there's an implementation in
nearly every major language at this
point so arcgis is not just for angular
and it can be used independently or it
can also be integrated just as easily
into other frameworks like view i've
even heard of people wanting to use rxjs
with reacts just because they like the
way that it works so there's even a tc39
proposal to add rxjs as main data type
the observable to be included in a coma
script 7 as an integral part of java
scripts that proposal has been sitting
at stage 1 but the point that I'm trying
to make here is that this declarative
stream based architecture approach is
quite popular and widely adopted so as I
talked about Kristen Bell a little bit
here I just wanted to do a Content
warning about the TV show Veronica Mars
it does have some heavy plot points
where she's kind of a young teenager and
then later in life you know grows up
into running the private private
detective agency she's she's along for
the ride here to help us crack the case
but this is about as spicy as we're
gonna get we're not going to talk about
any of those heavy stuff so this is also
from a show called hot ones it's on
YouTube if you enjoy spice which like I
do they take there it's an interview
show and they take the people through a
series of chicken wings covered in
progressively hotter hot sauce although
number eight is probably the highest on
the list and it goes up to ten so I
don't know about the progression myself
but I don't
that capsaicin extract so this was from
her episode of hot ones and it's quite a
good interview show they get quite a lot
of celebrities on there and because of
the endorphins from the hot sauce things
can get pretty real so it's a pretty fun
show to watch so anyway let's let's talk
about rxjs so when I first encountered
observables in angular I just I've got a
confession I wasn't really totally sure
what I was working with I'd work with
promises and react and angularjs and
then that syntax of chaining operators
and then subscribing for your final
result I was like okay that seems
familiar like we're just doing HTTP
requests and they they'll complete after
the one result instead of being a stream
of values over time and it wasn't really
until I wrote my first type-ahead search
that things really started to set in so
there are a number of key differences
between observables and promises the
main difference is that promises can
only ever yield a single value whereas
observables can emit multiple values
over time another advantage of
observables is that they are cancelable
with unsubscribe promises don't have a
cancellation mechanism promises are
always asynchronous but the series of
values emitted by observables it's
usually asynchronous but it can just as
well be synchronous like a range of
values promises are eager whereas
observables are lazy and what I mean by
that is an initialized promise
represents some process that has already
started happening but observables are
declarative so they're just the
definition of how to handle an event
stream they represent what would happen
but not how not when nothing happens
until your observable has a subscriber
and that describes the how and when
so observables have different chaining
mechanisms for different mechanisms for
chaining and subscriptions where your
promises are only going to have
then clauses and promises don't really
differentiate as much between the
transformational than clauses and then
clauses that are responsible for your
final execution observables can be
reused by multiple subscribers and can
also be set up to be retried but
promises will only execute once however
promises are always multicast where the
same producer can be shared among
multiple consumers but observables are
unicast by default we'll get more into
that multicast versus unicast here in a
few so observables can be created and
your transformations defined but they
won't run until there's a consumer or
subscriber promises are going to execute
immediately on creation here so this
just kind of describes what you do with
each of the promises in each case and
then unsubscribing from an observable
causes the listener not to receive
anymore values and it will cancel the
work but promises will complete once
they're rejected or resolved and they
can't be cancelled once they're
initialized there's nothing to do with
the unsubscribe observables are kind of
more comparable to events in JavaScript
in that you define notification handlers
and use them to process multiple values
over time so if you want to compare some
point maybe that's a good one
subscribing to an observable is a lot
like adding an event listener one of the
main differences though is that
observables don't tend to share the
execution of event with multiple
listeners on their own that's more of a
unicast versus multicast events just use
callbacks but observables do have the
advantage of being able to transform
values before passing them on to the
handler so to lay out some of this
initial groundwork about observables
let's talk about the three main types in
rxjs we've got the observable the
observer and the subscription that
connects the two the observer is a
wrapper around the producer of events
the subscription represents the
cick you ssin of those events and the
observer is the consumer of those events
and the observer will have next error
and complete notifications that it could
receive on that subscription from the
observable so your observable is the
most basic building block of Arc's
jeaious it's just a function that takes
a consumer and connects it to a producer
when we subscribe to an observable with
an observer we get back a subscription
that gives us a means to cancel the work
and unsubscribe the observer is an
object that implements the observer
interface by providing those next and
optionally your error and complete
methods corresponding to those values or
notifications that observable can
deliver next notifications are the most
important and most common type of value
coming from an observable they represent
that actual data that's being delivered
to an observer err incomplete
notifications however can only happen
once during an observable execution and
you'll only ever see one or the other
and nothing else can be delivered after
you get an error or a complete so again
to reiterate an observable function is
only executed then when that observer
subscribes to it so an observable is a
lazy computation it only happens on
subscribe the subscription represents
that ongoing execution the actual
reality of events so it has a minimal
API that lets you unsubscribe and cancel
from that subscription ascription a
subscription will live on until the
observable terminates by completion or
error or until you manually unsubscribe
every observable emits zero or more next
notifications and possibly one complete
or error notification but never both
error and complete termination by error
or completion is not guaranteed however
and again you're only going to see one
or the other and once it happens
the observable execution will end so
your producer is the source of values
for your observable so setting up the
producer isn't really a part of the
observable definition again it's a
rapper the observables only real job is
to set up the observer to listen to the
producer observables are said to be
either hot or cold and this is multicast
versus unicast an observable is cold
if subscribing to it creates the
producer or activates the producer and
each observer gets a unique instance of
that producer on subscribe' an
observable is hot if it closes over the
producer and is capable of sharing those
producer notifications so hot is
multicast cold observables are where the
producer is created inside the
subscription I hope you can all read
this example here this is from a really
good article by Ben Lesh describing hot
versus cold observables and I'll have
the links to my slides so you can look
up these articles and references
throughout if you want to do that later
so and here in this example anything
that subscribes to your source
observable will have its own instance of
the WebSocket that makes it cold our
source cannot be shared in a unicast and
can only send to a single observer also
note observables should also return a
teardown mechanism so we can remove your
listeners and here you'll see that it's
returning a function to close the
WebSocket so when you call unsubscribe
that WebSockets going to get closed and
you're going to clean up after yourself
a hot observable on the other hand is
where the producer is created outside
the subscription the observable shares a
reference to the producer and starts
listening to it than on subscribe' in
this example
anything that's
scribes the short source shares the same
instance of the websocket and now it can
multicast to all subscribers meaning
that each mess is it emitted by that one
socket can be received by multiple
observers but we do still kind of have
an issue here that we haven't really set
up a way to tear down and disconnect our
WebSocket so what we could do instead is
we could use a subject to make a cold
observable hot we create a subject that
has subscribed to by the cold observe
observable and then shared by the new
observable that we're gonna be returning
a subject is kind of like a traditional
event bus it's a hot observable and one
that can be shared by multiple
subscribers and producers subjects have
all the same operators as observables
and it will emit values that you next
into it so you can push values in and
subscribe to get values out so a subject
is another type that's involved with
rxjs subjects multicast and they keep
track also of an internal list of
subscribers and subjects are mainly used
for multicast scene so what subjects
have different from observables as they
have state subjects can't be reused once
they're unsubscribed completed or an
error occurs just like your observables
subjects are pretty sweet and they're
very important concepts in r.j. rxjs but
we really don't need to reuse them this
example isn't really how we would go to
make a cold observable hot and and Ben
Lesh will continue to describe that to
you in this article as we do here so we
we do still have a bit of an issue with
our teardown we're not tracking our
subscriptions so that cold source
observable so we're gonna be leaking
subscriptions and we don't have a way to
disconnect it so the thing is we don't
actually use subjects directly like this
because rxjs provides a bunch of
operators to solve this problem and then
some and we're going to be going over
more of those operators here in a bit I
think operators are
really the meat of ArcGIS for me the
important distinction then between the
subject and the observable is that a
subject has state it exists it has a
list of subscribers sometimes even keeps
track of a number of values that have
been next through the subject whereas an
observable it's just a function that
sets up the observation it doesn't know
anything about its subscribers it
doesn't remember any values that's not
its job so I feel like and why I wanted
to develop this talk is because the rxjs
learning curve is for me it was quite a
steep one it's a really broad API but I
think really the good news here is if
that if you're newer to angular at this
point I've been doing angular for about
three three and a half years
modern angular and like back then there
was breaking changes retired api's
painful configuration updates if you
want to talk about updates Sam Julian's
right over there and she upgrade so now
that we've gathered some of this
evidence about observables observer
subscriptions and subjects let's keep
climbing that hill and see what we can
put together with our agenda with arc
Jas is set up an observable data service
I like to use this quite often when I'm
not using ng rx so you can use this as a
store to provide data to multiple parts
of your application components subscribe
to the data through this service to
receive the latest values so the
components the data is just a set of
values so here we're also abstract
engaging
of this observable data service and
injected it here as the to do HTTP
service so then we can handle that
access separately and we can put our
observed illogic in one place
and handle our application observer
state here so this helps us not have to
be aware of
where those values are coming from
separating concerns and decoupling the
different application responsibilities
so in our observable data service we're
going to be using a behavior subject to
hold our store state when subscribe to
this type of subject returns the most
recent value from the stream or the
initial state if no value has been set
since the behavior subject has that
latest value in state it's possible to
retrieve it directly instead of off of
an observable you can just use subject
to get value but that's a very bad
practice and is actually code smell so
we don't actually ever want to expose
the subject from our observable data
service because we don't want consumers
of that service to next values into it
so what we're going to be showing
instead here is we'll use a private
behavior subject and then we we give it
a public observable using that as
observable from your subjects so that
you that's what you expose to consumers
this this store here it'll get
initialized at construction and that
behavior subject will then let
components get the data when they get
initialized and can subscribe even if
those components subscribe after that
data has arrived that's really helpful
for the timing of those asynchronous
events and in your angular application
so using a behavior subjects is a great
way of writing code that works
independently of the order of those
asynchronous operations such as like
calling your back end and then binding
your components to that data source our
components don't have to then know where
that data comes from or how it gets
loaded they just subscribe themselves to
the store right here so you want to make
sure then that you're always cleaning up
after yourself when you subscribe to an
observable so an NG ondestroy
you be sure to unsubscribe that
component for the store
because that subscription would then
otherwise live on for the life of the
application HTTP observables on the
other hand though it will they complete
after you get a response or there's an
error so you don't really have to always
worry about leaving resources hanging
around from your HTTP observables but
it's just a best practice try to always
unsubscribe I don't like to leave my PR
reviewers hunting through my code and
deciding whether or not my my
subscription has completed I like to be
very explicit about that it doesn't cost
you anything right our store
subscription stays open for the duration
and so again we're gonna be sure to
unsubscribe our components a cleaner and
more declarative way of using those
observables in your components is with
angular's async pipe instead of doing a
subscription directly in your component
it's a pretty pretty handy way of making
sure you don't have to mess with any of
that subscribe unsubscribe trace it
through you know the async pipe in
angular subscribes to an observable or
would also use a promise and it returns
the latest value that is has been
emitted the new values emitted the async
pipe also marks that component to be
checked for changes so you can use
angular's more performant on push change
detection strategy I think again the
best thing about the async pipe is that
when the component gets destroyed the
async pipe automatically unsubscribes
and avoids all your memory leaks we
aren't keeping also any state variables
in our components so we don't have any
of that messiness maybe you know some
people like to change their state inside
the component you're like what why would
you do that here you know so we don't
need to use our own in it we don't need
to use ondestroy
setup and teardown our data the async
pipe handles all of that for us off of
our observable another thing to know
here in this example is our - duze
observable how its named with a dollar
sign at the end of the suffix this is a
very common style convention
to help us distinguish those values as
observables but it's not at all
necessary to the observable
functionality just something that you'll
tend to see or might want to use
yourself so far in this year
investigation with Veronica we've
gathered enough evidence to see that
building our application in layers helps
us to decouple the applications
responsibilities our observable data
service or our store can provide data to
multiple parts of our application
however even though we're calling it a
store it is not the same thing as
centralized state management like redux
for example if you are looking for a
Redux solution there's an excellent and
very popular I love it Redux library for
angular called and grx so even though
we're not doing centralized state
management with this observable data
service though we do still have the
advantages of unidirectional data flow
like using that on push change detection
strategy so to make changes to our store
then what we're gonna need to do is use
action methods to update the store
similar as we would do in redux we would
send an action up and it would come down
out the store action methods Save
Changes to the backend service and that
then will return an HTTP observable so
in the stores action method we subscribe
to the HTTP observable to update the
data in the store and then we're also
going to return that observable too so
that calling components can subscribe to
it for the duration of the HTTP request
you know they usually want to know like
how long that request is ongoing and
when it's ready to declaratively show
the values
perhaps a loading spinner or something
like that so then since we're gonna we
are subscribing to that observable twice
once to update the store here and then
we're returning the observable and we're
going to subscribe to it in the
component for the eventual data we do
actually risk duplicating that HTTP call
so
the observable by itself is just a plain
cold observable setup to make a request
when a consumer subscribes so
subscribing to post multiple times will
actually perform one request for each
subscriber that's important thing to
watch out for sometimes I just I just
forget about it oops you know it's over
it's over here and the other concern so
what we would do it to prevent this
scenario on the HTTP call we're going to
use the rxjs operator share so that
share operator makes a cold observable
hot and shares the underlying
subscriptions between its listeners
that's how it works but just of in any
way with share when the first observer
subscribes it listens to the HTTP
observable triggering a single post
subscribers that start listening while
that HTTP request is ongoing they're all
going to get the same result so when the
source HTTP observable completes those
scripts
subscriptions will be terminated as well
so the observable being the foundation
of rxjs
the the real magic I think is in those
operators like share operators are pure
functions that take data or other
observables from an observable stream
and transform them into new observables
they enable us to write that complex
asynchronous code using declarative
composition there are two kinds of
operators we've got the pipe a bowl
operators and the creation operators
pipeable operators are those that can be
piped to observable and they'll take an
input observable and transform it into a
separate output observable they're often
composed with pipe as a chain of
operations you might have heard of pipe
and other languages kind of similar pass
it pass it on to the next chain right so
each one in line will receive input from
the previous
and share is an example of that pipe
operator as we saw earlier using that
with pipe creation operators on the
other hand are standalone functions that
can be called to create a new observable
the creation operators let you do things
like create an observable that fires on
an interval a synchronous observable of
any value an observable maybe from an
event or even generate a new observable
by compatible observables for example
operators are super super handy but I
think the thing about each one of them
is there's a lot to learn under the hood
about how they all work and what's
appropriate to use in each given
instance so back to share one thing
about share and the underlying
functionality that we want to be aware
of is that in making a stream hot share
also makes observables retrial
that's retrial not replayable so if we
subscribe after a value is produced
we're not gonna get that first result so
luckily there's a different operator if
we want the replay functionality we can
use share replay with the argument one
that one is an argument of the number of
next notifications to replay retry is
super great like if it's the thing you
want you can set up your observables to
retry on purpose here in our example
we're only going to be using our HTTP
observable during the duration of the
request so we don't really risk
duplicating those HTTP posts but just a
little bit about how share and the other
multi casting operators like it work is
what they do is they keep a ref count of
all their subscribers and four share
when that ref count when the number of
subscribers drops to zero or the
underlying observable completes causing
the subscribers to drop then the subject
created by share cannot be reused but
the subject comes from a factory and if
you
new subscriber after your rough count
has dropped to zero and it goes back up
a new subject is going to be created by
share retrying the original observable
and that is going to potentially
duplicate your HTTP requests so this
might seem like it's getting a little
complicated but it's just that there are
some specific multi casting operators to
solve for these different scenarios so
the big thing that you want to keep in
mind when thinking about hot versus cold
observables and how we're going to be
subscribing to them is kind of what's
happening on the underlying producer and
that producers side effects so a side
effect in functional programming is an
event that updates application state
outside of the called function one of
the properties of pure functions is that
they don't have side effects the side
effects in these examples would be the
HTTP requests sometimes we need to make
an observable hot and share the
execution and result or often we can
just use our cold observables carefully
and subscribe to invoke them
independently
so I'm going to show you this smaller
kind of a stand-alone example to further
emphasize the point about the acing pipe
and the potential for accidentally
duplicating HTTP requests so we've got
everything going on here in this one
component we're doing a get call to get
our list of two do's and we also want to
show a total number of the to do's so
we're set up we set up a different
observable piped off of the original
observable and we've decided to get the
length property off of that list of to
do's right so in the template we're then
using the async pipe to subscribe to
those observables and here what we're
actually doing because we've got an
async pipe on the total and we've got an
async pipe on the to Do's we're actually
subscribing to the original observable
twice with our async pipes and so that
is going to duplicate our HTTP requests
and you might be thinking like why the
heck don't we just use that share thing
that we just learned about right it
isn't always necessary to share your
streams there was a really sweet feature
that came out with angular 4 template
syntax where you can use the ng if with
async as and you can assign the values
coming off of your observable to a local
template variable so that you can then
use that throughout your template block
for the values so you aren't subscribing
with your async pipe twice it's
something to look out for
additionally with the ng-if and async as
you can add an ng else clause so you
might want to show an alternate template
block when the observable hasn't yet
admitted any values so what I've added
here is a loading block to kind of show
off how the ng elf's would work this
reactive template Styles syntax really
simplifies our code making it more
declarative easier to read and fewer
state variables are going to be
littering up our component classes so I
think reactive templates are pretty
sweet y'all so not too long ago rxjs 5 5
introduced pipeable operators this was a
shift in the rxjs api that changed the
syntax of chaining operators so instead
of dot chaining the patched the
operators that are patched off of
observable we're going to use the pipe
herbal operators with the observable
pipe function this also changed the way
that we import our Kaos GS operators and
really ease the burden on managing
dependencies and improved our tree
shaking capabilities so we can ship
smaller bundles to the browser so we're
using observables pipe method to compose
a series of operations here each
operation
we've got filter map and scan results in
a new observable and pipe then produces
an output observable that you can
subscribe to and perform your actions on
so here what we're doing is we're
filtering the values by the even ones
and then we want to take those even
values and double them and what scan is
doing is accumulating some at each
result at each interval so marble
diagrams depict
how reactive operators work with
observable sequences we're gonna be
looking at a lot of marble diagrams for
operators from here on out so I I want
to just kind of describe how each one
one
these work this is from the ArcGIS
documentation it's their their diagram
and I think it really shows a really
good description of what these marble
diagrams mean the top portion that
you've got above the box here we've got
one input observable that represents the
series of values it reads from left to
right and it ends there with a line with
the complete notification the observable
operation usually is in the Box in the
middle here we're calling it multiply
multiply by 10 the output observable is
shown then on the bottom observable
sequences are shown as lines that emit
zero or more values in a perpendicular
line for your completion or output
somehow has an X for error I'm not sure
what happened Y multiplied by 10 got so
hard but you know things happen maybe
maybe there was a side effect
so transformational operators like map
are I think some of the most basic
building blocks in your rxjs dreams
similar I think to the well-known array
map function you might want to compare
it to that the map operator applies a
projection to each value then it emits
to the output observable but I think a
big difference in the way that map
operates on arrays versus how it
operates on observables
that you want to keep track of is is map
will operate all all of the operators
they operate on one value at a time as
they're streamed through the input so
the array map function then on the other
hand operates on the entire sequence at
once so it's kind of a paradigm shift
and it really does make a difference
when you're looking at these operations
and and thinking about how expensive it
might be to operate on arrays vs.
composing streams with observable
sequences so filter then is one of the
many filtering operator
it filters items from the source
observable and only emits those that
satisfy a given predicate function it's
also very similar and can be compared to
the array filter function and that it
filters those values from the final
result again they're only being operated
on one at a time as an observable stream
there are quite a few other filtering
operators including distinct debounce
throttle last take until and then some
we'll get into a few more here in a
while another operator that might be
familiar from arrays as they've provided
a find operator it searches for the
first item in the source observable that
matches the specified condition and then
it will complete maybe although somewhat
controversial another operator that I
wanted to talk about that's similar to
arrays is reduce reduce is an aggregate
operator that outputs only when the
input observable completes though on the
other hand what you might be wanting to
reach for with observable is instead of
reduce is the scan operator scan is a
transformational operator that emits an
accumulated result at each interval so
frequently when you're working with
streams you want an intermittent result
rather than waiting for a single
aggregated result at completion so this
is another example that shows how you
might create a type of head search I've
got a link here to adjust that going to
show you this code we don't need to read
all through it I'm gonna break down the
pieces that are important so we're gonna
create a type-ahead search with rxjs
kind of learning by example so on key up
here what we do is it processes the
search text input into a subject stream
that is filtered through a chain of
operations that check it for minimum
length they d bounce the input or wait
for a break in the keystrokes that's
what d bouncing means and it only emits
then if the value has changed too
stinked until changed so writing these
operations in plain JavaScript I think
would otherwise probably be quite
involved so we do have the general idea
I think of filtering down but let's look
at that debounce time and see what it's
actually doing for us waiting for the
break in keystrokes debounce time delays
values emitted by the source observable
and it will also drop previously pending
delayed emissions if a new value arrives
before the specified time
so what rate limits the input and delays
the output you can see that how the the
ball is kind of line up here versus the
input and which ones got filtered out
because they were D bounced distinct
until change then our next operation in
that search type-ahead search does
exactly as you might think it omits
values only if they were different from
the last value we received the distinct
until changed operator forces
distinctness only from the most recent
value if you want full and uniqueness on
your stream you can use the plane
distinct operator and then you can also
compare those values using a key
selector function another thing that you
can use operators to avoid is nesting
subscriptions nested subscriptions can
become quite hard to manage and they're
difficult to follow and they take your
application straight back to something
that looks like callback hell that's not
why we're using rxjs is it so in this
example that we're showing we've got the
ID route parameter observable and when
you receive to that when you receive
that route parameter you want to go
ahead and fetch the data related to that
ID from your service and that's a
separate dependent observable so don't
do this do not
Nestor subscriptions Nestea and
subscriptions is considered a very bad
practice what we want to do here instead
is use a higher-order observable
operator to flatten
or to join to the dependent in our
observable stream and then only
subscribe once a higher-order observable
is an observable that emits other
observables that's all it is it sounds
fancy but it's an observable of
observables difficult to say maybe
Arceus provides several operators that
flatten these observable of observable
streams and turn them into ordinary
observables so here we're using switch
map on the latest routed ID and then we
combine that ID with the service to get
that data based on the ID we assign that
result to an observable that we then can
use in our template maybe with a spacing
pipe if you don't know which higher
order operator to use when starting out
I think switch map can often be a safe
bet but we also should examine how it
works if you ever see cancelled requests
in your network tab sometimes I'm like
oh where am I using switch map that I
shouldn't be that shouldn't be happening
so switching is just one of the ways
that we can flatten observable is in
rxjs with switch we're subscribed to
each inner observable as it arrives
output will come then from your first
inner observable until we get another
one and then the initial observable is
unsubscribed - and cancelled so that's
where we're gonna see cancel so for
flattening operators like switch you've
in your in your marble diagram the
higher order observable is often
represented as the topmost line that
emits your inner observables switching
is a very specific behavior that when we
want to receive values from an inner
observable and so we get another
observable in which case we cancel the
previous one and hand over control to
that new inner observable the observable
then completes on completion of the last
output observable so you might have
caught here that d are our fourth value
the blue ball is missing from our
outputs
and the reason that is is because our
second inter observable it came along
so our higher-order observables
subscribe to your second observable
canceled the first inter observable and
it drops D from the output even though
the second observable hadn't yet emitted
any values that was the active inner
observable at the time so we are missing
D can cat is another observable
flattening strategy that is also
subscribed to only one observable at a
time however it waits for each inter
observable to complete before
subscribing to the next one this process
is each of the inner streams fully into
the output stream in order of their
arrival a third strategy that you're
often se is merged very common merge can
subscribe to multiple and our
observables at the same time and it will
emit values from each one as they arrive
merging those values into the final
output with merge though the order of
your output is determined generally by
the timing of your input so as you can
see if your values arrive
non-deterministically in a certain order
or not that's how your output is going
to look so you can't really depend on a
certain ordering with merge that's
frequently while people might use can
cat to take one in our observable after
another
emerging come cat operators come in both
flavor of observable your pipeable and
your creation operators your plane merge
is a joint creation operator that
subscribes to all input observables and
then emits each of their values as they
come through right
the pipeable merge operators which we're
showing here are merge all merge map and
merge scan merge map is a combination of
map and merge all it allows you to play
a projection to those merged values and
returns an observable of each value and
then flattens it into the stream so what
we're doing in each of these examples is
the same thing in the first one though
we've got that bad inner subscription
that we're not keeping track of so we're
mapping our observable to an observable
of an observable stream and then
subscribing to that inner observable to
actually get the data we don't want to
do that right our second one we've
decided oh wait we want to flatten those
observable of observables with merge all
and then we can subscribe for the result
but the quick one to reach for here is
the final one merge map that just lets
you apply that projection and flattens
it into your final stream so to combine
streams
we're often going to use the join
operators they're both join creation
operators like can count and merge and
then your pipeable join operators I
might need a little more water up here
before I finish it combined latest and
with latest from our some of these joint
operators they're pretty similarly names
but they have distinctly different
behavior when it comes to updates so
combine latest is a join creation
operator and allows any of the input
streams to to update the output stream
with latest from then is a is a join
creation operator and allows any of the
input allows the inputs excuse me
it allows so that what the with latest
from does is it the only the leading
stream puts results into the output
we're gonna see a diagram here in a
minute that explains this more correctly
both of those operators result then in
an array in the next notification thank
you so much so the values from the input
observables are returned and given an
order than in that array another thing
that both of these operators with latest
from and combine latest have in common
is that in your combined your combined
output stream is not going to emit until
all observables have emitted at least
one value this has caught me a time or
two so the output stream is waiting on
all source observables which can be it's
kind of a subtle behavior I think until
you run up against it
and you you want to emit even if only
one of those streams has emitted in
which case what you might want to do is
you can kick off those streams with the
starts with operator or possibly you can
fall back on emerging strategy or
something like that to to get values in
the input as soon as you get a sink in
the output as soon as you get a single
input so as you can see here in these
diagrams we're not actually emitting
anything until both observables have
emitted a value so you'll see that that
your ax in your combined latest your
result that first ball only comes out
after your second stream has emitted
values and because with latest from will
only emit from your leading stream you
don't get a value when you hit a because
with latest from blue balls has not
emitted anything yet you don't get a
value when you hit X because that's not
your leading stream so you're finally
going to see a value when you hit B and
you get then the combination of your
leading stream and the the latest value
emitted from that second stream
so another type of operator take is a
filtering operator in rxjs what it does
it omits the count of the number of
values from the source then it
immediately completes as shown here in
the diagram we're taking two values from
the stream and completing our count is
two but would take if the source emits
fewer than count values it will just
emit all of those source values and then
it will complete when the source
completes similarly the take until
operator is also needed when you need to
complete your operations but it's when
you send a notification to a stream that
it should complete the second observable
is the notifier and when that second
observable emits of value the first
stream will complete however if the
second observable never emits any values
or it just completes all of your values
from your source observable are going to
be emitted so here's one way that you
might use take until instead of keeping
track of all your subscriptions and then
having to unsubscribe from each of them
you can pipe all of your streams through
a take until operation and then you can
next into a destroy subject that will
emit a value on on destroy of this
component and then it will complete all
of these subscriptions so here we're not
using the async pipe as we normally
would in our template just for the sake
of example and when the destroy subject
receives the next notification you're
going to be able to clean up after
yourselves and those subscriptions are
going to be completed this really saves
us a lot of hassle of having to keep
track of and unsubscribe from each
subscription but again like we've
already talked about different
strategies that we can use and maybe you
don't even want to have this many
subscriptions that you're keeping track
of and a component so that's kind of why
I call this a weird trick but it's it's
a good one that people often use as
back up just to be sure that they're not
having any memory leaks so typically as
we learned earlier with your reactive
templates we would have used that async
pipe and so we wouldn't have to keep
track of any of those manual
subscriptions but then one thing that
I've really run into within my
components is like how the heck do I
know
and debug what that value is on that
observable if I can't access any of
those values on my stream in my
component class like what what is even
going on I can't observe my observable
so one quick way to peek inside your
observable streams and for maybe those
logging or debugging reasons perhaps
performing this side effect that doesn't
affect the observable is by using this
tap operator tap can perform your side
effects or your output and returns your
stream unchanged so it allows you to
inspect your observable stream without
having to subscribe to it remember that
it does have to have a subscription now
let me correct that it has to have a
subscription in order for it to be
active so maybe you subscribed in the
async pipe as we said so remember that a
stream then can either terminate a by
completion or it can error out and once
an error occurs the stream won't emit
any more values there's not going to be
a complete notification and when it's
true when it airs out we we can't use it
anymore it's done
so sometimes handling those errors in
your subscription callback and just
allowing the stream to complete that's
sufficient that's what we want
but rxjs also provides a catch error
operator in the case that we want to
catch errors in the stream and allow the
stream to continue instead of letting it
terminate by error so catch air is
expected to return a new replacement
observable that is going to be used
instead of the stream that aired out it
allows us to go ahead and contain
you so when used with the higher-order
observable operators catch error
prevents the air from bubbling up into
the stream and then still allows the
inner observables to be subscribed to
and process then into your output a
common place that you would see catch
error that I have used is with an jrx
state management applications because
you're often dealing with observable of
observables and you want those streams
to be able to continue maybe you want to
deliver an error to your ng rx store
instead of the results but you don't
want your application to fully break
right so we have talked about a lot of
the operators and but the thing is
Arceus has so many operators I only have
so much time today these are a grouping
of the few types of operators that we
have discussed
I think this grouping really helps sort
it out and provide me a way to figure
out how to to kind of work with my
streams and think about what I want to
do and to reach for the correct operator
so it's clearly it's not going to be
helpful for me to just kind of list them
and tell you about all your operators
what we need are some strategies to
connect those dots and create us a
mental model of these operators and the
various reasons for using each type of
operator the creation operators then
what they allow us to do is to create an
observable from just about anything
observables are just declarative
abstractions again of how to process
things from a stream so the creation
operators are there to wrap other
processes like events requests timers
etc to create those observable sequences
out of them
so the purpose none of your join
creation operators is to be able to
process more than one of those streams
as a single stream similar to how maybe
your higher-order operators flatten the
observables of observables but instead
of having a stream that's piped of
observables piped through them the
join creation operators create a new
observable stream from a set of separate
observables so like playing from cat
playing merge those are your join
creation operators combine latest is
even a join creation operator next we've
got our join operators and those are the
pipe herbal operators that let us bring
other observables into the stream like
your with latest from or your merge all
that we saw earlier transforming values
as they pass through a stream is such a
common scenario that they combined
joining with transformation for the
higher-order operators like merge map
and concatenate the multi casting
operators as we talked about first like
share allow us to use observables as
subjects that can be shared by more than
one consumer your filtering operators
conditionally emit value values into the
output based on that input passing a
given predicate function the conditional
operators also look for a specific
condition or predicate function to be
met however they will emit only on
completion of your stream the error
handling operators are there for
preventing the stream from airing out
when dealing with the inevitable errors
that can occur when you're working with
non-deterministic and unpredictable
outputs and side-effects perhaps like
HTTP the aggregate ones operate on an
entire sequence at once and like the
conditional operators they only emit on
completion the utility operators then
add to our arcs Jia's toolkit by letting
us inspect log or perform side-effects
we can repeat delay timeout or convert
an observable and to anis or maybe an
array another way to find what you're
looking for with arkshya's operators is
by using the operator decision tree in
the
ah yes documentation it will ask you a
series of questions about what you're
trying to do and take you eventually to
the correct operator for what you're
looking for so I've extracted some of
those decisions here for finding the
right creation operators the decision
tree doesn't I think really cover
everything and this is only again one
branch of it but hopefully this kind of
helps give you an idea of just how many
operators they are the vastness of rxjs
but all of the different reasons for
needing to use each of them and finally
I think when troubleshooting your
observables which is an often a thing
that we run into in order to crack that
code
it can really help to start off looking
for some clues like how has this
observable been subscribe to and how
many subscriptions does this observable
have potentially duplicating any any
requests you want to think about when
does this observable complete or if it
completes and also again do I need to
and should I of course you should
unsubscribe from your observables so
given that I've tipped you off to some
of these strategies and tricks and with
definitely with practice and some
investigative sleuthing on your own I
think that you should probably be able
to solve any case that you run across
and if you really haven't gotten enough
and you're hungry for more rxjs content
I think that you should consider
attending rxjs live in March right here
in London just look at all these amazing
speakers I I can't believe I'm one of
them early bird ticket sales do end for
this conference tomorrow
so ask your boss get that approval get
in on those early birds get in while the
gettin's good
early birds get the worms so I really
want to thank you all for attending my
talk today I'd be happy to take any of
your questions and your green feedback
cards and this is linked to my example
code on github which also has a PDF
these slides in github and if you want
to go ahead and just use SlideShare to
click through I have a link to that as
well and I'll leave that up for you so
you can grab those thanks again
[Applause]